[Music]
welcome back the true news if you can
yeah building going on outside or flat
you can you can't the sound is fine no
complaints in the comments thank you
very much just appreciate what you're
given you absolute bottom feeders
otherwise Brian will come into your
restaurant and find you sexually
attractive and nobody wants that
yes look we do it when we won saw a very
sweet tweet though the other day this
girl said I rely on you for my
relationship to keep going wears true
news Zoomer yeah God if we're keeping
the relationship together that is a
first for me
James child's he does what he wants
junior he's really coming to his own
this year so to speak of his dick in his
own [__] change shoving my Pinky
Dinky at my own [__] you tatty little
woman hottie where we're from
it doesn't probably mean the same thing
nice I called and sort of like something
you'd find in a in an old sort of shop
yeah it's like a touchy cord if you know
what happened yeah you update me because
I haven't followed it as closely as
Allah so I was working at teg eyes on
the Friday night and there was a small
group of youtubers that came in at the
time I thought nothing of it Brian but
as the evening went on I saw as a family
with a friend and I went over to get the
order from the table I'm tearing up now
even thinking of it he just kept saying
to me I could have you if I wanted I
could have you if I wanted and his
friend kept saying you couldn't he's
straight when he just turned to me when
I'm famous
is that all Jim wells did wrong no I did
some other stuff as well it was quite
offensive the way that he tried to turn
straight men gay his type is apparently
straight men so you his type me
definitely is time and apparently this
Loess made a video about it because he
chose to promote a rival brand what it
sounded like when I first watched some
of it was like I wasn't gonna say
anything about James Charles being a
total [__] but now that he's promoted
something that's opposing what I'm
trying to sell now it's not okay behind
my pockets no more James that was the
main problem lying my pockets were all
good lay in the opposition's pockets now
I'm grossing you off she's a bit of a
[__] as well
whoa we can't call a woman a car
I think that's a little far she's quite
powerful as well is she yeah well
subscribe to troop Geordie yes oh it's
not the way it works in order to want
millions of people to watch you you'll
be couldn't yeah in order to be selfish
and concentrate your whole life about
making yourself look good not tough to
be he did a bit of an apology video did
he yeah
will make up for this one can I just say
yeah yeah perfectly handsome lads
doesn't need all that all I can't go
yeah I mean you can't sell bare face
though Brian can I just say the irony is
that we're listening to this this week
cuz I speak it in charge on a joyful
karaoke system so I bought him look yeah
is that still here he does look like
he's been crying a lot at this point
maybe he looks like this has a bit of a
messed up so I got a wild night some big
straight man just holding on to his hey
take it to Tom's Westbrook I'm sorry for
everything that is going on everything
I'm sorry for putting you through me
promoting a brand in opposition to you
you money-hungry [__]
literally what does he put us through he
got a [__] paycheck off her me took
my money and he promoted some [__]
worry about your own company for example
we've got sponsors if someone promotes
something else they learn opposition
there I'm going to [__] crack on just
because you're my friend doesn't matter
exactly yeah this is ridiculous for me
the issue in it all is the fact that
they did it all publicly she helped this
guy from day one so fear whatever
yeah but knowing the ownership from her
point of view they're like I helped make
you yeah and now you're gonna promote
him that is against what I'm promoting
[__] you that's not cancelled what a
load of wank that is yeah cancel cancel
yeah if anyone says you're canceled
you're never canceled the fact that
people care enough about you to say it
cancelled means you're actually very
relevant you're fighting go to someone's
[__] I'm off right now just one of
those strict they really do give a good
suck job maybe sat down upon it was like
that's even got a [__] apology out
well you suck on this dick yeah I meant
to you and James almost three years ago
when I first went into the industry and
when I had no friends and nobody to talk
to when you're wanting people to forgive
you ah you want them living little
lonely James coming into the industry
not knowing anyone know Dexter so yeah
not a celebrity
you can't just in a restaurant yeah you
they can't do nothing yes the lineup
with all the normal people are just
practice drawn on his face with brushes
and Tati
very quickly took on a parental role I
think we get what happened he got lost
in the [__] and started getting up
his own ass and just thinking he was the
[__] is this a genuine apology does he
even care how do you know you don't
judge a man when he has nothing judge a
man when he has everything so I'm
thinking he's got everything now and
he's acting like a dick apparently every
single person who ever gets Fame and
rich at some point you don't act like a
dick at some point one thing I've gotta
say is I'm a bit tired of canceled
culture because it just feels like
people because other people benefit from
it they go we could try and it's always
about trying to [__] people like it's
always about sexual oh he's a predator I
mean let's be real this guy is not a
[__] predator he did exhibit
predatory behavior yeah he acted like a
dick maybe I'm I'm saying it differently
because it was on a man and maybe if
it'd been on a woman I would have seen
you're the waiter and he could have you
for one I feel happy if I won I'm famous
I'll have whatever I want I'll have you
how do you respond I would ignore it and
just continue and sort of see it is like
oh that's a little bit funny isn't it
also because when I look at him I don't
go there's a chance this happening you
don't follow a new home and jump and
unuseful
even if you didn't follow me home I'd
still just go okay goodnight James
there's not gonna be a moment where he's
getting smushed and one of the people
know Nath who smashed him Jeffrey Stehr
today's video we're going to be
discussing Jeffrey star finally coming
for James Charles the irony yesterday
was so insane and I know they say that a
lot I think he's just been cast as a
Vulcan in the new Star Trek movie with
with people when they have like
surgery to look like aliens do all his
brother tweeted why does everyone act so
tough on the Internet now Jeffrey star
quote tweeted Ian and said why is your
brother a why did you really move back
to New York City
exactly shut the [__] up ah and that is
the T he's got a bit of a vested
interest in this cause James Charles is
coming for the make of King Queen sort
of crown the dangers to society those
Mentalist yeah this is crazy because
literally this means nothing I've just
sent you a message from someone that's
percentage of swimming in regarding
jeffree star who's the real danger to
society so he groped a man's [__] i
kneeled on the bed so that was something
he did so people are like you know who
were you to see to me this all felt very
unsatisfactory it all felt very like
people just cashing in they're trying to
get their big click if you're a queen
yeah you're coming to have that sass and
attitude on this they're all gaudy of
course they're gonna act like dicks it's
not okay you know I mean but they're all
as bad as each other
it says Bruno would say inissia machine
it must be quite traumatic when you're
at the eye of the storm and Kardashians
unfollowed you another famous person I
feel like YouTube is like that place no
people want to build you up to knock you
down them right do anything wrong you're
gonna [__] up when you're a young person
on YouTube yeah it's like in that time
you'll find out like what your real
friends are and stuff like log and well
and truly earned it but I think this is
really harsh and exposing my DMS with
James Charles let's look at that slow
one random day James Charles and my
teens and then this is where it kind of
led into what I thought
and have you heard the [__] music
he's using you think it was Star Wars
yeah I'm expecting lightsabers I want to
pull those that fall if you replace
those locks
guys I was the victim of James Charles
here's me jumping at a pool this is
where it kind of led into what I thought
it was going to lead into oMG how old
are you oh em gee how old are you
no no it's not how old you it's how
old's are you how old are you yeah you
know why he can't text properly he's
wanking 19 love that nineteen a man cuz
at the time his child is probably like
18 a cougar he's messin you're a little
crazy actually to be fair we are
laughing at what could be ultimately
sexual harassment there's nothing about
this that is leading anything else
besides a flirtatious approach he's not
doing anything wrong by flirting with
this guy yeah that's not illegal hasn't
done anything wrong yeah yeah this isn't
some sort of docking situation when when
someone starts flirting with you then
you're like poking out of the tractors
like hey yo let's film a video being a
seriously I didn't want to like use him
I don't want to do any of this so I just
trying to be nice
like y'all let's film I don't want to
use one of the fastest-growing youtubers
in the world would want to use - hold on
wait so his logic is this person is
messaging me to either flirt or come
unto me and I'm gonna ask him to be in a
video with yes oh sorry what's your
motive for messaging this person again
just go sorry James
we have no business here in the nor do
you help people instantly slip into
roles yeah so in this one James is the
man yeah and this straight guy is the
traditional girl right James once his
Hall and he wants to use that want to
get what he wants out of it which is
money from views and subscriber and
again this guy is the [__] this is
where it kind of confirmed for me why he
was in my DX said perhaps just because
you're cute as hell so once again a
flirtatious approach in my DMS and me
just getting kind of uncomfortable again
could've put phone down could have not
replied could have said uncomfortable
with this yes what what did a video of
them saw curried on reply
being truthful I've had damage off men
before who were clearly gay oh you
showed me that guy that weird he was
really weird I didn't put it out there
on the internet door you have a bit of a
laugh yourself crying I don't reply
I didn't reply right you didn't say hot
cast no I think to be fair most guys
especially this guy most youtubers
you're interested in women gay guy comes
on you you don't reply he replied oh you
just go replies he's completely because
he had something he wanted out of this
situation just as James Charleston as
far as I'm concerned [__] this he knew
exactly what he was doing there [__]
but I did want to mention the fact again
just to let him know that I have a
girlfriend so I have a little studio set
up at my girls house of course when I
say that that's all he was in my DMS for
and no response but a little over a
month later I get a DM I don't know
where on November 20th he said oMG you
are literally so hot so once again
beyond flirting with me and says I was
just stocking your Instagram I think
James tells forgot talking to him when
he went girl's house James went delete
and then he was oh oh the odd [__] in
the same ways Michael Jackson data type
James Charles has a type that's very
different but yeah let's do that episode
of deeper secret soon again still trying
to get a video still replace exactly
this shows what a [__] this guy is
James odds are still coming for the hall
and he's still coming for the YouTube
collab why doesn't this little [__]
[__] just give his all so and then get
he's [__] collab because everyone
gets what they want think when you do
break it down what you just said is this
man should have anal sex no just get
James to a video if James Charles was
just a gay guy with no YouTube following
you wouldn't be replying I know you
wouldn't be
he's replying because he wants the
[__] video so right when women do
this sort of thing it's like it's tacky
before all time for a man [__]
messages of him pathetic honestly this
is just [__] us [__] James is just
horny honestly that's all this is he's
sitting there he's browsing Instagram
you see him and thought yeah I would I
go back to your phrase Brian an
upstanding dick knows no mercy
alright and you know that you know I'm
joke Paul and Tyler they're all the
YouTube channels are based on drama in
what their lives are I kind of feel like
they're perfect for each other but
they're also absolutely terrible this is
how I dress for when I'm meeting another
parent she's got nose
Clint's necklace and and that one more
time man and I don't think I should go
too early
you know I'd love there's all these
people achieving this in the vlogging
you're just ledge is going holy man and
snap I'm bad and bronzed your site
forget you guys go all my two favorite
girls it's gonna be marred watching
Jake's love life for the next 20 years
yeah it's just gonna race through these
girls just cut next one next one and
another and then when you go back
through his youtube channel it's just
gonna be like so many blondes just got
to admire it on a fare Fox to the good
do you have to a pirate I [__] good on
Jake always gets the tits on on come
refer please I mean to be fair it's very
difficult to sort frame them out isn't
it there no but he's making sure that
there is consoling like my camera way
again Logan's gonna go into the Russian
yeah yeah this is the guy who he's gonna
go up against it's an open handed slap
that you've got to tick you can't flinch
you can't get out the way basically
first to be knocked out it seems losers
he's not a huge guy in terms of height
it doesn't see him but he's thicker than
a Snickers it's gonna be Logan
slap the [__] taste out of his mouth
this is the world concussion
championships right yeah like if you
wanna have guaranteed brain damage this
is the game for you like at least in the
UFC
you can block you can put your hands up
you can get away like you can protect
yourself
you're literally car-crushing yourself
doing this pretty yeah I've actually
been close to the messaging and
personally me like they say in it chief
like you need yeah not do this cuz if he
wants to box JJ after this it's a fact
if you watch fighting you got knocked
out once the lights go off much easier
vine because it's almost like a learned
response that your brain causing to
react it's to protect yourself the more
it happens the easier it happens again
so if Logan goes in this and gets
starched which this guy is an expert at
doing that yeah and he gets knocked out
and then he goes in fights JJ in six
months performance time whatever it is
and JJ hits him on that same spot you'll
be more likely to go out again like I've
seen logon practice in his slaps okay
yeah he's a fit guy he's kind of [__]
do good he's gonna be decent this dude
is like a little windup slapping machine
that's like blends Sunday dinners down
and house like five a day or something
it's almost better to have what he's got
marriage is that bit of misrata
Buddha being yeah a long way it's like
just power he's not an athlete he's just
there to destroy evil organ take a few
slaps of him then [__] me fair play but
it's just mad me if you remember that
youtuber who kissed his sister nice
kissing his mum you see you know is one
where he goes around just kissing
pregnant women they're all actors fit
we're pregnant I mean I don't know I
suppose you can shove a cushion up your
shirt and it makes it look that way
isn't it if you really want to impress
me get the ultrasound done right
yeah and then I'll stock the face off
you said Brian my kissing my sister
print all of those views and you're
still recording on a pile of [__] on a
potato why are you using a potato to
film your videos even I don't do that I
used to kiss my mom when I was a kid no
like that I used to be like night mum
bang yeah I had Nutter glass school kids
I kissed everyone in my family when I
was a kid it's not in that way nah but
that was just a little Peck wasn't it
this sister one he really got into it
yeah he wanted to [__] his sister busy
if he was neck down with his mum I'd be
like alright fair play make you know all
right
know you've got yeah now I respect
everything about you I would kiss his
mum it's fine it works
Game of Thrones chat now spoiler alert
there's five hundred thousand signatures
going out onto a petition for Game of
Thrones Season II to be rewritten with
competent writers insulting people are
pissed off yeah did you sign it haven't
too busy replying to my James Charles
DMCA we got a collab took a lot the
podcast would actually make a good
pocket are definitely we know there's a
trade yeah I'm ready for mine said to me
are they ultimately a wormhole is a
wormhole
mmm-hmm any hole is it gold but the
gamer that's what we were gonna call the
kickoff originally a lot of people
aren't happy with Game of Thrones
because Daenerys is now the bad [__]
she's the mad queen some people say oh
it's because that they didn't get the
ending they wanted they wanted a happy
ending and that's why they're unhappy
pain I disagree things have gone wrong
in the past on Game of Thrones before
Ned Stark the main character killed end
of the first series a red wedding where
his son was killed it was an awful thing
where everyone was miserable that they'd
lost favorite characters but it was
great writing it was settled well and
even though it was an unhappy ending a
series or whatever people still loved it
no one ever mentioned the writer the
reason people are mentioned in the
writers now it's because Daenerys
there's been very little setup to her
turning from a good guy into a bad guy
yes she's done things previously in Game
of Thrones which could be considered
kind of bad but she's always done good
things in amongst that and including two
episodes before this saving the world
she's gone from saving the world to burn
in the [__] world it was too quick of
a turn to rushed it wasn't well set up
at all for shuddering and setting
something up are two different things
and it hasn't been done well and now
we're on to the last episode and I just
hope that they don't [__] it up worse
for the record I've got no problem in
the making and Daenerys a bad guy
just make it a slow descent into madness
where she's clearly struggling with that
battle inside of it like they did on
Star Wars for Anakin Skywalker like that
would have worked well but the oven it's
always wasn't even great well
millionaires don't watch Star Wars we'll
see what happens in the final episode
I'm not looking forward to it you don't
watch it watch i watch episode 5 just so
I could chat with you about it and then
you've gone and done a monologue I was
hoping I can interact a bit on that no
no you don't watch the rest of it I have
to I mean I've seen where we up to it's
a bit like North Korea situation for me
we got rid of Kim jong-un girlfriends
that is all there are lovely pair of
tits has just got and put that on Wow
she didn't even pick a good picture of
them dude she doesn't give a [__]
literally she is a billboard for the
skies they break up now she's in trouble
she's I'm not sure well I should that
will be very painful though you know
just sort of around there that's a very
sensitive part of the body for you know
winning or make it into a montage and a
like a call-out of things but bit to
puckery shoulders on one leg goes
I mean she's like she got hip-hop
legends piki all over there why do you
get a six-lane that big
yeah just loved him loved him at the
time it was a really influential album
you wouldn't get it 2 Chainz in the
background I love bad [__] that's my
[__] problem and yeah i like to [__]
I've got a [__] problem he she is
sucking off a [__] octopus again
probably shouldn't try it eat it alive
should you you [__] it you know I
love is that she's been bitten by the
octopus and she's going oh no and the
octopus is like if I can have a bit of
that yeah good on him yeah you [__]
dick this guy is the new wolf of Wall
Street BAM very good love that that's
really good that is amazing yeah we get
the concept he knows those housewives I
hold my god oh yes we get it it's sort
of therapeutic though I never get sick
of watching I'm just chopping yeah he
must have done that take so many time it
is the wolf of Wall Street there is one
forward question you must absolutely
never ask a man if you want him to be
your boyfriend or your husband or
anything beyond just a hookup who you
never hear from again what's that
question Brian what forward forward
question do you love me I find out here
Brian okay question is the fact that I
guess that before any answers amazing
it's as if you have a craft of the
English language or that I'm a man I'm a
man James is this guy the kind of guy
that you would take relationship advice
from I certainly wouldn't take um
sharing advice yeah how can his have his
head to be so bald and his arms be so
furry
maybe he did that he wants to get that
shave it often in plundered teach you
the shocking and strange truth about
masculine psychology and why men pull
away and introduce you to a simple three
word phrase that forces a man to
automatically open his heart let down
his shields and commit to
you three would what raise three word
phrase with that thing [__] me harder
hope it has opened my heart yes my
shields down lines just even saying it
myself
and I'm committed to protect you if
you're listening to this on iTunes or
Spotify I'm looking the camera now I'm
talking to you not Lawrence so you quite
like this story because you do actually
love KFC this man was going into KFC for
all year and saying you've been sent
from head office to test the chicken and
they were basically giving him free
chicken so he can test it every single
time he used to walk into the KFC
walking with a lot of confidence and
tell the employees that he was sent from
the KFC headquarters for Quality
Assurance oh it's pretty cool you can
walk in and go hey obviously quality
assurance again
well again you did it yesterday no they
want you every day we were unsure on the
rap yesterday I was no sure I wanna try
some legs under bargain bucket please if
we could wrap that up the goal and as I
say yesterday the rap is weak so if we
could have improved that today that we
fantastic thank you every day there will
appear all like the man is a legend yeah
that's what I thought
it's that kind of entrepreneurial spirit
I can get behind
yeah these people youtubers Thank You
Tube is right but also a couple there's
a word for prong youtuber [__] right and
those people were going around Walmart
and pretending that they were from head
office again more people from head
office but they were firing employees
basically just come in and they've just
sat random people that's so hot social
experiment what do people do and they
get fired the social experiment when
you're making people think they can't
for to feed their kids anymore
hilarious you're working oh yeah I'm the
CEO of this Walmart and the CEO of this
woman I'm sure anyone would believe that
acting I'm the CEO of this Walmart I'm
checking on my employees and stuff how
anyone fell for this [__] is amazing
now Brian have you ever tried to fix
your sink with noodles that's right
we've all done it put the noodles there
chef shove shove glue on the noodles jug
shove shove Wow he's making a sinker
noodles that looks really nice I
literally had no idea well he's noodle
dead the noodles will dissolve no Brian
no and I don't think we ever get to see
that anyway too flawed concert no
noodles fix sinks okay he's right you
seen this one this is my favorite
Scarface this is me out of depression
you can beat it it is very beautiful
he's wrecking a van or a car yeah
hi oh hey Hales I think we've
misinterpreted my youtube link check it
out see what you think drop some comics
force and in the meantime we cool go do
stuff Wow his Rick's looking quite cute
they're literally doing there I hope
tubes Charles doesn't find this one I'll
have good I'm gonna be droppin a new
YouTube video of next couple days but
this one concerns one of my confidential
conversations with somebody
confidential name ID literally the
nature of confidentiality restricts a
good lad had some tough times and
bouncing back from it he's a good
inspiration everyone out there if you
just want a little bit of positivity
right go and find it yeah on Instagram
and Rick Cowley if the time isn't right
then work on the time and make it right
hashtag go do store credit or win yeah
let's go see Rick Cowley yeah check him
out
it's got a youtube you haven't already
to do go do stuff I just want to relax
and watch a bit of the big old BVM don't
skip the adverts please lads go on a
charity walk lost interest and the guy
we're gonna go and do any literature
went
Dave is doing what all youtubers do
which is try to make their own videos
more entertaining and when someone's
boring the [__] just cut them off
they're not a bit all to be scoped I
think they used to be scattered they're
not scouts anymore there's a lot of
people eating at this dinner table of
charity money there's probably not going
to be a lot of money is there I don't
think so I worry yeah a fiver here yeah
we'd like to give you a 5 honestly the
processing fees more than I just keep it
to yourself
there are all charismatic like they're
working well together these two are like
true Geordie and Lawrence on this place
a couple of weeks ago I needed to get
some vapor do I determine to the bake
shop across the road and I said to the
wife come on quarter there of course he
bakes is a modern man and he's in Los
Mochis in his old school
he's moving with the times long yeah I
mean Brian named a more iconic juror
I'll wait just goes on yeah recording
making sure the record is checking that
yeah I think so yeah for that I've loved
with the WWE come and eat watch this
like we used to watch WWE when we were
younger yeah I'm sure he watched like
the rest of them we watched it and a
little bit often yeah yeah my popularity
seems to keep growing Oh God this is
where I start I'm actually falling out
of love with the WWE it was women things
where I used to make the three-hour and
the two-hour thing the part of my life
I've actually missed raw and sometimes I
don't even bother with Smackdown can I
just say though it's mad how many I grew
up with a lot of men who stuck with it
like you know when you've got a point
where you're like yeah
done a lot of my mates stuck with it and
even I've heard from them they're like
it's all [__] it's just it's so
different for this generation like I've
had to change it so much basically
they've once saw PG and and you know
everyone knows it isn't real but like
there was always that element of these
guys seem like they could really kick
off in real life so that's me there's
not also not enough for like the mankind
type wrestlers anymore where there's
like yeah it's for me it's hard
they've all got names like Zapp Branigan
like it's always a Chuck flush like ya
dig they've all got really [__]
characters yeah it's it's sad when
YouTube is offering better more and more
like personality yeah then he'd writers
can
and I don't honestly understand what
Vince McMahon's thinking why are we
having Brock lesner making about some
superhero just turns up once in the blue
moon when I pay for that I've actually
cancelled the subscription to the WWE Oh
oh my god I'm sad now so they need to
hire him in some way as a good creative
director an exec producer so I'm just
overseeing things I just do we need
Brock really you know I think he could
really help structure the storyline
right so that's the end of today's true
news but don't worry we've got more
coming later this week come on tap he'll
do no that's PSF assistance this
wheelhouse we've been we've been
traveling to a principal we've been
seeing the world and also I might have
been given $300,000 car whoa it was an
experience I'll never forget and I've
got a video so you can live it to enjoy
you're welcome subscribe like the video
comment wolfsie is fuckingly
karaoke